I am now going to give an overview of
ancient Greece in future videos we're
going to go into a lot more depth on a
lot of these events and ideas but this
one is to give you context on the big
picture and just to start let's begin
with the name Greece it turns out that
the Greeks do not call where they live
Greece neither did the ancient Greeks
they called it L us L us L us and the
word L us comes from Ellen so this comes
from Ellen which is this legendary
figure who is viewed as a progenitor of
the Greek people you could kind of view
him as the father of the Greek people
and it's not well-established in the
historical record when Ellen actually
existed but this is where we get the
name
Ella's from and it's very important do
not confuse this Ellen who was a man
with Helen of Troy
Helen of Troy was a different person
when I was a child and I heard about
Hellenic things or the Helen Hellenic
period or the Helene's
I was like oh maybe that's something to
do with Helen of Troy no that's
referring to the Greek progenitor Ellen
and so that's where the word Ellis comes
from and ideas like Helens which is the
Greek people or Hellenic which is
referring to something that is Greek or
the Hellenistic period which we'll talk
about many viewed videos from now which
is this period of Greek influence not
over not just over Greece and the
Anatolian Peninsula but over Persia and
over Egypt so with that out of the way
let's now talk about the big the the big
arc of history of ancient Greece and
it's believed that the Greek Peninsula
has been settled by human beings for
thousands and thousands of years and as
time goes on we'll hopefully understand
more and more about them but my time
line right over here starts with
Mycenaean Greece which is or it starts
with the end of Mycenaean Greece and
other videos we might talk more about
the Mycenaean Empire and as that Empire
Falls we enter into the Greek Dark Ages
and the
it's called the Dark Ages is there's not
a lot of historical record of this
period roughly between 1100 BCE and 800
BCE
now there's one event and I'll kind of
say that with a slight emphasis or a
question that is worth noting here I
have Trojan War question mark around
1200 BCE once again there's not a strong
historic record for the Trojan War but
it is a famous war that was chronicled
by Homer and even Homer we don't know if
he really existed or whether he was an
entire literary tradition but it was
chronicled in the Iliad and the
aftermath in the Odyssey and once again
this was chronicled many hundreds of
years later and even Homer is a is a
semi legendary figure but when people
talk about the Trojan Wars or you see
movies about it we're talking about
something that if it happened the way it
happened it's on the order of 1,200 year
1200 BCE now as we exit the Greek Dark
Ages that's when we start to have some
of the institutions that really that we
now identify with the ancient Greeks get
established
you have the Oracle at Delphi the Oracle
of Delphi often known or Pythia often
known as the Oracle of Delphi this is
where leaders of the Greek city-states
went for direction to understand what
was likely to happen to get prophesies
and this institution the Oracle at
Delphi lasts through this entire period
I have on my timeline into Roman rule
for over 1,000 years where the Oracle of
Delphi is a very very prominent figure
in influencing Greek leaders at around
the same time you also have the Olympic
Games where they are held at Olympia
where people compete to show their
athletic prowess and this ancient
Olympic Games once again it continues on
for over 1,000 years our modern Olympics
are you know just to kind of a flash in
the pan which and it was obviously
modeled after the ancient Olympics
compared to how long this
lasted now when most people think of
Greece they're actually talking about
classical Greece so this is the
Classical period right over here we're
going to do videos a lot of these events
but it's roughly in the period between
the the Persian invasions that were
successfully put off and the rise of
Alexander and the fall of Alexander and
that's where you have all of these ideas
of of Greek democracy really kind of
coming to the surface Pericles the
Strategos of Athens who had the
influence to really help democracy
flourish under his leadership or during
his leadership you have the acropolis
and the Parthenon these famous icons of
Greek culture being established but once
again this is in this period that's in
this period right over here this is also
the period that we associate with the
famous Greek philosophers these lines
right over here are the lifes of
Socrates and Plato who's Socrates
student established the famous academy
Aristotle who was Plato's student and
famous tutor of Alexander the Great
now as I mentioned you had these
city-states and the ones that are worth
mentioning or all of them were worth
mentioning but I have in this diagram
the most significant city-states of
ancient Greece that you'll hear a lot
about we talked about the Oracle at
Delphi the Olympic Games at Olympia a
lot of the conversation tends to focus
around Sparta and around and around
Athens and then you'll also hear a lot
about Corinth and Thebes Sparta is
famous for its militaristic Society they
it's often glorified but it's also worth
noting that they were significant slave
owners at different parts in Spartan
history they had somewhere between seven
and twenty slaves for every Spartan
Athens is famous for its philosophy it's
famous for it's the birthplace of
democracy is famous for its art it's
famous for its architecture actually all
of these areas are famous for its
architecture but it's also worth noting
that during the Golden Age
you have the Athenian Empire they were
also pretty brutal and putting down
rebellion and in some ways subjugating
different people so it depends how you
want to view things and we're going to
have a lot of videos on all of these
things but at that time we talked about
these city-states even though they
shared a common language and common
culture they went to the Olympic they
sent folks to the Olympic Games they
went to the Oracle of Delphi they were
independent states and it wasn't until
you have Philip of Macedonia in the
fourth century right over here when he
starts to really unify these Greek
city-states and it culminates with his
son Alexander the Great and Alexander
great not only unifies Greece but he
takes over the Persian Empire and and
really kind of with his death and he has
a very short life he ushers in the
Hellenistic period where you have Greek
culture influencing that entire region
not only Greece not only the PERT would
what was a Persian Empire the Middle
East Egypt that whole region gets
influenced by Greek culture and Greece
at the I guess you could say at the end
finally gets under Roman control and it
depends which date you want to use it in
the middle of the second century BCE is
when Greece itself Falls to Rome but
then other parts of I guess you could
say the Hellenistic world finally
succumb to Rome for example Ptolemaic
Egypt in the first century BCE but even
then even when it becomes part of the
Roman Empire it influences the Roman
Empire very very very heavily now other
things that you will hear us talk about
when we discuss the Greeks besides their
the democracy in the philosophy we're
going to talk a lot about Wars and it's
worth it's worth noting what Greek
warriors look like so this is a
depiction of hoplites
which are Greek citizen soldiers in
ancient Greece and you'll also hear
about a phalanx of failings is the
formation where they walked or they they
marched very tightly together and when
archers came they would put all their
shields up and they'd almost be like
this armored
Hank and it was it was a very effective
method of warfare another word that you
will hear associated with Sparta and
those slaves is helots those were the
names of those slaves and they weren't
owned by individuals they were actually
owned by the state now some of the other
cities here
Corinth will come up a lot it has a very
strategic location in the Isthmus of
Corinth notice to get from the mainland
or I guess into the Peloponnesus the
Peloponnesian Peninsula you have to go
through this its --mess Thebes right
here was a significant rival to Athens
at different periods of Greek history it
was the dominant city now the last thing
I want to mention is there's just a ton
of culture that comes from the Greeks
and a lot of words that we even use
today for example the word draconian
which is used for something that's very
harsh well that comes from Draco's law
which came in the seventh century BCE
from Athens he he composed he was a
theme Ian's legislator who composed a
very harsh series of laws and that's
where the word draconian comes from when
people say something is Spartan they
kind of imagine it's something that's
very basic or you you just have the
necessities and it comes from the idea
of Spartan culture that they really
everything revolved around military
necessity even the word laconic which
means someone who doesn't you know says
just enough to get their meaning across
it comes from the region where Sparta is
Laconia the Spartans were famous for
their kind of very terse speech famously
when philip of macedon was threatening
the spartans and he's saying if you
don't come on to my side i'm going to do
this and that to you if you don't become
part of my kingdom my empire i'm going
to do this to your city i'm going to do
that to your people and the spartans
famous reply was if which is kind of a
good example of laconic speech with that
one word they were able to convey a lot
so I'm going to leave you there in the
next few videos we're going to go into
some depth on this but it's important to
realize that when people talk about
ancient Greece they're talking about a
large span
history and most of what we associate
with ancient Greece the Acropolis the
Parthenon the Persian Wars these the
great Greek philosophers most of that is
associated with the Classical period
often associated with the Golden Age
which is right right around there that
well before this period the Greeks
weren't all you know these philosophers
sitting around in togas they might have
been wearing togas but at this these
earlier periods they were more
adventurers and conquerors and they
might have been in small villages and
eventually those evolved into the the
city-state that especially in Athens and
Sparta had their Golden Age in this
period right over here